what's going on everybody and welcome to
a brief video covering sponsorships on
the channel so if you haven't noticed by
now there's like a little blue sponsor
button what this is is YouTube has
rolled out a way for individual users or
subscribers to a channel to actually
sponsor that channel for five dollars a
month so I've just been kind of poking
around with this and for a couple of
perks at least initially out of the gate
for sponsors I thought it'd be cool so I
have like this huge list of over a
hundred topic ideas that I would like to
do on tutorials and usually I just kind
of pick one willy-nilly so I thought
it'd be kind of cool to let sponsors
instead be the ones that pick you know
usually from like a list of maybe the
top five things that I'm curious about
doing right now let the sponsors pick
the exact things so also I've pulled
topic ideas just in my regular just in
the community tab on YouTube and then
that gives me like a general idea of
what people are looking for but then for
an exact series I can ask the sponsors
like hey do you want this so I thought
that would be a really cool perk to
start with also I have to upload videos
to unlisted they all videos get uploaded
now to unlisted first for two reasons
one is D monetization you have to leave
it up for at least 24 to 48 hours before
you know if it's going to be demonetised
for who knows why and the other reason
is a lot of times I have to still have
to write the text based version of the
actual write-up and this could take me a
few days or even a week or more so that
would be relatively benign to give the
sponsors just access to the unlisted
videos I would ask that of course you
wouldn't share it or whatever but you
know whatever
doesn't really matter so I thought it
would be cool to do that as well now if
you can't sponsor or don't want to
sponsor or whatever that's totally fine
nothing changes for you you still see
the same content videos aren't going to
like stay unlisted longer or anything
like that it's just I thought those were
two relatively benign perks that I could
offer
that wouldn't hurt anybody else oh I
almost forgot the most important thing
the reason why anybody would would
sponsor is if you do sponsor you'll get
like a little badge next to your name in
the comment section and then also if in
when I stream you get access to a
handful of custom emojis send text theme
stuff anyways that's all for now if
you've got questions comments concerns
whatever leave them below otherwise till
next time